hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and in this video i'm going to be
talking about service accommodation
is serviced accommodation dead is it
buzzing
is it dead but will be buzzing what's
happening right now
can you make money doing it should you
make money doing it all things service
accommodation
if you like my videos do me a massive
favor just take a second to smash the
like button
also subscribe turn the notification
bell on
if you're not already because i'm doing
videos every single day and they're kind
of good videos so
service accommodation for anyone that
doesn't know what is serviced
accommodation
it's very simply when you rent out your
property but instead of renting it out
to a normal tenant on an ast contract a
short
shorehold tenancy you rent it out on
short
stays short stay bookings so an example
of a short stay booking would be
you might rent it on airbnb and you rent
it out to guests
people might have parties in there maybe
not you probably don't want to do that
or people might stay there cottages
cottages.com booking.com like a hotel
this is a short stay you're not a tenant
you just stay there
for a day a week maybe even a month but
you stay there for a short
period of time now what's the massive
advantage to doing service accommodation
well the obvious massive advantage is
cash flow because if you're renting a
property out per night instead of per
month
you might get 100 pound a night instead
of 500 pound
a month and you can see very quickly you
can generate a lot more profit
because people are prepared to pay more
because they're staying for a short
period of time
so cash flow is much better for service
accommodation there's also with service
accommodation
there's lots of tax advantages as well
so for example if you're
buying a property to rent it out
serviced accommodation you're going to
pay
commercial rates for stamp duty which is
considerably less tax
commercial tax reasons for service
accommodation you can also
claim more things back so you can claim
a lot of things as tax-deductible
expenses
that you wouldn't be able to do if it
was just a regular buy to let
i mean another thing is section 24
doesn't apply for service accommodation
which means you can claim back your
mortgage
payments whereas you can't do that
unless you buy through a company when
you're doing buy to let so there's tax
advantages
there's cash flow advantages but is it
working at the moment that's the big
question
that was the purpose of this video are
people wanting short stays
well it all depends on the type of guest
that your property is catering for so
there's four types of guests
which will generally stay in service
accommodation properties
there are tourists now tourists are what
most people think of when they think
short term lets you know they think
maybe
uh get someone that's traveling on
holiday if you're in
stoke on trent you might be thinking
okay well would service accommodation
work in stoke on trent maybe water world
or alton towers isn't too far if you're
in birmingham you could be thinking of
all the tourists so
that is the is the first type of guest
you've also got
business professionals these are people
that will just need to stay somewhere
overnight maybe they've got a business
meeting they're traveling for business
doctors dentists lawyers entrepreneurs
the types of people that you might see
you know you go to the village hotel
the village hotel is filled with people
and suits and briefcases and there's a
lot of business people staying there for
maybe they've got a conference
a meeting a one-on-one meeting they're
meeting up for a coffee with someone
with really important meeting
they need to crash at a hotel business
people really important
next are contractors
now contractors i'm talking about people
that are going somewhere on a contract
to do a job like
a really good example would be builders
so if you've got a built a team of
a small team of builders five or six
builders and they're being
they're being they've got a job to do
but it's not near their house
so they've got to travel each day all
the way you know four hours away to go
and work on a project together they
might just say you know what rather than
traveling back and forth
this job is going to take us two or
three weeks let's find a hotel
let's find a house that is on serviced
accommodation
where we can crash there for a couple
weeks we'll be we're a contractor
we'll sleep there and then we'll go and
we'll work and it's close to our job
they're contractors
really common really really really
popular and
and often good you know really good
players and then the last type of person
is reloading
relocators all right cool relocator that
means you're moving house
right now october 2020 people are moving
house all the time
people are moving workplaces they're
being told to work from home
they're moving back university students
are saying actually i'm not really
you know a lot of this is all virtual so
i can move back to live you know back
near my family
so it's a lot of people moving house in
fact how sales are a record high right
now
people are moving house people are
selling house people are you know so
the reason they'll people that moving
house will want to stay in your service
department
or your service combination property is
very simple if you're selling a house to
buy another
or even if you're renting a house but
you want to move in another usually
there's a little bit of a discrep
discrepancy between timing so it might
be a case of all right i'm handing my
keys back to the landlord or i'm selling
my house
on the 1st of november and then i'm
moving on the
2nd of november to my new house but what
happens is there's a delay there's a
hold up
where you can't sell your house on time
or something it doesn't quite it's like
oh man but i've
i've got this house secured so you think
you know what i'm uh i'll
i'll move out or the other way around
sorry okay so there's a hole up here so
you saw you think i'll sell my house
and then i'll stay in a serviced
accommodation property for a week or two
while i wait for my house to complete
that's a relocation doesn't normally
happen on the same day
normally you might need to stay for one
night tonight somewhere
serviced accommodation property and
these people will pay top dollar
another great thing about relocators is
they think it's going to be for a couple
of days or a couple of weeks it can end
up being for
months but they're paying top whack uh
because they don't want to stay at
necessarily a hotel they want a kitchen
area
a little lounge area so they'll pay top
whack so these
are the four types of guests that will
currently
stay in your service accommodation
property now is the market dead is it
dried up that's the big question
depends on your property tourists
right now tourism is dead not just in
the uk worldwide
if you have got a property and you are
marketing it
and pitching it to tourists it's not
going to happen
because what what can you do right now
you can't really go anywhere you can't
travel
it's hard it's difficult sure some
people are traveling
but if your property is tailored for
tourists
you're going to be getting massive
discounts you know and you're going to
be
half empty at best so you're going to be
really really struggling
however business right now is booming
people are people are still traveling
people are still doing business
in fact at the moment a lot of people
their offices are closed so they're
working out of rooms and staying and
moving and meeting
so if you're if your property is
tailored to business people
it's great and how do you tailor your
property to business people
very simply let's say it's on airbnb and
booking.com rather than having pictures
of
cadbury world and having pictures of the
beach and pictures to try and entice
tourists
instead you're gonna you're gonna you
know make sure you've got a little work
space in in the room and you're gonna
tailor and market it specifically as you
advertise the rooms with business people
in mind
contractors booming crazy busy
relocate us massive because everyone's
moving house
so this is why it might be strange maybe
and listen maybe your particular area or
maybe if you've got a beach house
a little guest house on the beach it's
gonna be really quiet right now
so i'm not saying all serviced
accommodation is booming but at the
moment service accommodation is not dead
as long as it's the right property so
what you need to do is if you have got
this
type of property you need to switch it
and you need to tailor to the right
people
right now 2020 is a very interesting
year
and people say you need to pivot pivot
pivot you know adapt what does that mean
well what that looks like for the
property entrepreneur is instead of
pitching your properties
to tourists tourists right now tourism
is dead win it pick back up
sure it will at some point i don't know
when it's going to be probably into into
2021 so you need to be thinking
how can i market to these people right
now a lot of hotels are full
if you are about to take on a service
accommodation property property
do your research on the area check what
the hotels are doing
a lot of hotels are full make sure
you're marketing to the right people
but service accommodation right now in
2020 is not dead
it's just it needs a little bit more
pivoting and it needs a little bit more
thought
you can't just get a property and whack
it on airbnb and it'll be fun you're
making loads of money
you need to really think about who your
market's going to be
and make sure you're only taking on the
right properties in the right areas but
by no means is it dead
if you want to learn more about service
accommodation and you want to start
doing
rent to service accommodation or buying
properties to rent them out as service
accommodation if you want to learn about
the tax advantages
you want to learn about the areas where
to do it and all the benefits of service
accommodation
to work out whether it's the right
strategy for you then you could either
join me on a webinar which is completely
free
and i'll leave in the description a link
to a service accommodation webinar below
or if you're really serious and you're
like samuel i don't want to go on a
webinar
i just want to come and meet you in your
studio
and do this and make it happen then we
do have the property investors academy
which is reopened which is training
mentoring
bespoke coaching and if you want to talk
about the academy you want to meet me
then i'm going to leave in the
description
a link to our discovery day which is a
a short day about half a day four or
five hours
with me in my home office here at the
studio
with just a maximum of 10 people where
we can talk about your strategy
we can discover all the different
options and work out a plan for you
and also we can talk about potential
further training if that's right for you
if it's not that's fine so there are
some options
but what i would not do is i would not
give up and do nothing i would not
wait for things to get better things
already
are better things are very very much
okay
people are making massive money every
single week i'm taking someone on
winners on a wednesday
and and people are becoming successful
every week the opportunities are massive
you just need to take the right action
and get the right knowledge
and and dream big dream big and take the
right action because honestly the
opportunities are out there so i'll
leave links below
join me on a webinar at least if you're
really serious join me at my home office
here in buckinghamshire and um please
don't forget to smash the like button
subscribe and i look forward to seeing
you on the next video thanks so much